Si on croit en ce qu'on fait, on peut faire fi du reste.
J'ai pris mon courage à deux mains, et je suis sortie de la voiture.
Mes jambes tremblaient.
Je leur ai demandé : « Que puis-je faire pour vous ? »
Devinez ce qu'ils m'ont répondu.
« On sait qui vous êtes.
On sait où vous vous rendez.
Tous les jours, vous vous rendez dans le nord de la ville.
Vous éduquez les femmes, vous leur enseignez.
Vous leur offrez une chance d'avoir un travail.
Vous les formez. Et nous ? »
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
« Et nous, que faites-vous pour nous ?
Que va-t-on faire ? »
Je les ai observés et j'ai dit : « Je l'ignore. »
(Rires)
Ils ont répondu ceci :
« OK. La seule chose que nous savons faire
depuis que nous sommes nés, c'est tenir un fusil et tuer.
C'est tout ce que nous savons. »
Vous comprenez, n'est-ce pas ?
C'est un piège, évidemment.
Je me suis écartée d'eux et ils ont dit : « Vous pouvez y aller. Partez ! »
Je suis rentrée dans la voiture,
et j'ai dit au chauffeur de faire demi-tour et de retourner au bureau.
A cette époque, nous ne formions que les filles.
On avait des budgets juste suffisants pour former les femmes,
les envoyer à l'école, sans plus.
De retour au bureau, mes éducateurs avaient disparu.
Ils s'étaient enfuis, à l'abri dans leur maison.
Il n'y avait plus personne.
J'étais seule avec mon garde de corps.
J'étais muette et pétrifiée.
Alors, je me suis assise et j'ai dit :
« Qu'est-ce que je vais faire ? »
Comment résoudre ce problème ?
Nous formions déjà des femmes dans le Nord.
Elles étaient des centaines à venir pour suivre nos formations.
J'étais là, prostrée, et c'est à ce moment précis,
quelle coïncidence,
c'est à ce moment qu'une de mes donatrices m'a appelée à propos d'un rapport.
Elle s'est interrompue et a dit :
« Sakena ? Qu'est-ce qui se passe ? Tu n'es pas toi-même. »
J'ai essayé de relativiser et j'ai répondu que tout allait bien.
En dépit de mes protestations, elle ne m'a pas crue.
Elle m'a reposé la même question : « Dis-moi juste ce qui se passe ! »
Je lui ai raconté ma rencontre du matin.
Elle m'a proposé de les aider la prochaine fois.
« Tu leur apporteras ton aide ! »
Deux jours plus tard, sur la même route,
je pensais les retrouver, mais ils n'étaient pas là,
ils étaient postés un peu plus loin.
Le même groupe d'hommes, debout, le fusil à l'épaule,
nous indiquant d'arrêter la voiture.
C'est ce qu'on a fait.
Je suis sortie de la voiture et je leur ai dit de m'accompagner.
Ils ont accepté.
J'ai donné une condition : « Quoi que je vous demande,
vous devrez l'accepter. » Ils ont accepté.
Je les ai emmenés à la mosquée,
et pour faire court,
j'ai mis à leur disposition des professeurs.
Aujourd'hui, ils sont devenus mes meilleurs éducateurs.
Ils ont appris l'anglais et la pédagogie, l'informatique.
Ils sont aussi mes guides.
Ils nous précèdent et nous accompagnent,
dans toutes les régions montagneuses, qui nous sont inconnues.
Ils nous protègent.
Ils,
(Applaudissements)
Merci.
Quel exemple du pouvoir de transformation de l'éducation !
Quand on éduque des gens, ils se transforment complètement.
Aujourd'hui nous devons œuvrer en faveur de l'égalité des sexes.
Nous ne pouvons pas former les femmes, et omettre de former les hommes.
Car les hommes sont ceux qui soumettent les femmes à des conditions inhumaines.
(Rires)
Dès lors, on a commencé à offrir des formations aux hommes.
Ils doivent en effet connaître le potentiel des femmes,
le potentiel des hommes,
et la capacité des femmes à accomplir les mêmes tâches qu'eux.
Nous formons donc les hommes aussi.
Je crois beaucoup dans le pouvoir de l'éducation.
Je vis dans un pays qui était magnifique.
Je voulais partager ça avec vous.
C'était un pays magnifique,
beau et paisible.
Nous pouvions aller n'importe où.
Les femmes recevaient une éducation :
elles devenaient avocate, ingénieur, professeur.
Nous allions régulièrement chez les voisins.
Nous ne fermions jamais nos portes à clef.
Hélas, vous savez ce qui s'est passé.
Aujourd'hui, plus personne ne se promène sans craindre pour sa vie.
Mais nous souhaitons ardemment que l'Afghanistan redevienne comme avant.
Je vais vous raconter une autre histoire.
Aujourd'hui, les femmes d'Afghanistan travaillent beaucoup.
Elles reçoivent des diplômes, et des formations pour devenir avocates.
Elles sont formées à la médecine, comme avant.
Elles deviennent professeurs,
et elles gèrent des entreprises.
C'est merveilleux de contempler ces personnes atteindre leur potentiel.
Tout ça est en train de devenir réalité !
Je tenais à partager ça avec vous, parce que l'amour, la compassion,
la confiance et l'intégrité, quand ils vous guident,
vous permettent d'accomplir de telles choses.